hello everyone and welcome to today's
session tutorials
data analytics i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event so let's get started
before we begin
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen today's session
includes
dr trevor mckee dr ellad david amir
and dr rafael guitardo each will present
and have a q a following their
individual presentation
i now present today's first speaker dr
trevor mckee
a senior data scientist at the star core
facility
at the university health network
presenting on the topic of
integrating spatially resolved
biomarkers in the tissue
micro environment with quantitative
image analysis
on imaging mass cytometry data sets
for complete biography on dr mckee
please visit the biography tab
at the top of the screen dr mckee
welcome you may now begin
your presentation sir
thank you very much for the invitation
to come and speak to you today
my name is trevor mckee i come from the
star image analysis core facility at the
university health network in toronto
and i'll be speaking to you today about
some work that we've been doing
both within our core as well as with
multiple collaborations
including specifically dr jc villas pose
at the mayo clinic
i like to start by saying and now for
something completely different
i'm a bioengineer by training who's done
a lot of work on
image segmentation and image analysis
and i'm really taking
a sort of engineering approach to how to
move from pixels to cells
in order to interrogate single cell data
on tissue sections
stained either with ihc multiplex
fluorescence or imaging mass
so uh i'll do a brief background then go
into some comparisons of uh
analysis techniques between these uh go
over our general overview of how we
approach
imc image analysis and then look at some
challenges and future opportunities for
imc segmentation and analysis
so as i mentioned i work at the star
image analysis
the star core facility we're
pre-clinical multi-modality imaging core
based in princess margaret cancer center
where we have we have a number of
collaborations with
pathologists radiologists clinicians
academic researchers and also industry
we work to provide both uh pre-clinical
imaging as well as analysis
to academic and industry clients since
about 2007. and we really span
all the range from designing experiments
through treating imaging
performing the analysis and then the
ultimate goal of course is translation
to
the clinic really i wanted to
start by saying of course imaging and
analysis methods are quite important
whereas maybe historically one might
have considered
a tumor growing in a mouse as kind of a
black box where you
really only measure a few parameters
maybe tumor regression and or survival
and maybe some endpoints the advantage
of imaging
is that you can really see a lot more
about what's going on
both inside the tumor and around in the
in the tumor micro environment and this
gives you uh the
capability of uh much more mechanistic
insight into
uh what's happening during the course of
therapy
and maybe other mechanisms to uh
develop better drugs drug development is
a challenge
so this is a graph showing moore's law
the number of times this is on a die
growing exponentially
in drug development there's actually
iran's law it's moore's law backwards
so the number of drugs approved per
billion dollars of u.s spending follows
an inverse exponential
this is one of the reasons for this is
that the drug development pipeline is
really quite leaky for every 10 000
drugs that come into the
process you might get one proof drug at
the end at the end
so really um the other thinking of uh
doing enhanced pre-clinical testing and
imaging
um is to try and de-risk some of those
candidates and
identify candidates that might be more
successful
as well as over the course of clinical
trials trying to develop
companion diagnostics and biomarkers
that could
again help to specify patient
populations
and try to get a higher success of
approvals for for drugs
tumor immunotherapy of course is one key
area
where it's critical to know both the
per cell biomarker distribution as well
as spatial localization
um on this slide and you can see that
um you know uh tumors exist in a
continuum from sort of inflamed to
excluded to not to
immune desert likewise there's a growing
number of biomarkers
that are associated with either the
tumor cells the
t cells and dendritic cells and the
macrophages within the tumor
such that it's been said in in industry
that fundamental knowledge of biotic
biology is what's actually driving the
pharmaceutical industry nowadays
particularly in immunology so
at star we have a number of different
techniques available to do radiotherapy
imaging as well as we can extract
tissues and then perform
brightfield or immunofluorescence
imaging mass cytometry autoradiography
and then my job is to take all of that
data fuse it together and try to produce
results publications and help with
threat development we also have a number
of
sops and other operator support
available
and we the reason to have multiple
modalities
is that they exist across a range of
both spatial resolutions well
sensitivity
as you can see you know whereas ct can
get reasonable spatial resolution
it has rather poor molecular
sensitivity then that you have to inject
lots of contrast asians
whereas um pets is a lot more sensitive
but um
but suffers from limitations in spatial
resolution
ihc immunofluorescence and imc all exist
in the you know sort of at the tissue
level
at about one micron per pixel but with a
range of sensitivities
as well so um
this is an overview of what we do at
star
we're a small but dedicated team that
works both with academics
um to where where uh we try to help with
clinical clinical investigator initiated
trials
to develop advanced pathology analytics
try to integrate with the imaging
experiments that are happening and
deliver results we have also
interacted with a number of
pharmaceutical companies as well
where we perform analysis as a service
to those former clients and there the
requirements fall a lot more around
making sure we can get reliable outputs
robust validation
and a fast turnaround for data so that
includes the number of
again documentation and sops and other
things
so uh when you think about image
analysis
a lot of the tools that we use were
actually adopted from
satellite imaging so this is an example
here where you can see
we have an image such as this you can
group similar pixels together into super
pixels
and then use the information present in
the
borders and distances to help to
classify those super pixels into
your cars your roads your buildings etc
likewise in the tissue we can take the
same approach
and use the dna content
to identify the nuclei and then maybe
also
simulate cytoplasm and membranes
according to
the biomarkers that are present and then
assess
the intensity of various biomarkers
within those regions
so we take a we try to take sort of a
hierarchical frame
approach to image analysis where you
first identify
tissues within the whole slide and then
subdivide those tissues into individual
cells and then maybe
localizations we work very closely with
pathologists
to guide this algorithm development and
make sure that the outputs that we are
preparing are valid and our goal is
really to have an online pipeline for re
reproducible analytics
from either internal or external data
and there's a number of references that
um i'm happy to share
so uh first uh speaking about
immunohistochemistry um
comparing the different modalities
immunochemistry of course is
used routinely in the clinic can be very
reproducible
however the disadvantage is generally
one single marker per stain
and thus you need to identify cell type
by morphology
so we can use stain separation
techniques to help quantify these
these uh data and um this is actually a
bright generalized sort of bright field
pipeline that we've
developed at star where we take
individual sections
align them together then perform stain
separation
followed by cell segmentation and then
post
uh post segmentation classification um
fault and then finally quantitative
numbers generate numbers and
quantitative readouts
and then here's an example of stain
separation of segmentation
uh and then gland detection uh but one
very important thing as i mentioned was
um uh qc invalidation so um do we need
you need to be able to have a
methodology for uh determining
how accurate your cell segmentation is
and um
because the cell segmentation actually
uh will bleed through into all of the
subsequent results
and we found out we found out that this
is the case
it's because we've had a number of
experiences with
uh seeing that machine learning can
actually make mistakes
so it very much depends on the data you
feed it and how you
look at it so this is an example of a
bright field tissue section with the
transgenic
tumors growing in the lung our initial
machine learning output
said that all of the tumors in the
orange regions however when we went back
and looked in more detail we found that
actually a lot of those regions were
actually
bleeding and red blood cells were
accumulating around the tumor
area so we had to go back and very
diligent
graduate student actually went in and
manually annotated all these regions out
to make sure that the
final analysis was accurate we've done
this as well
on cell counting applications with this
one
application working with dr susan doan
who's a pathologist
here where we were comparing manual
counts by a pathologist
on p67 proliferation against our
automated counts and we found that
we got reasonable correlation likewise
we've done this
in multiple biomarker setting in a
clinical trial
where we've uh where we generally tend
to
uh tune the algorithm to get between 80
to 120
on uh of the manual counts
that that the automated account sees and
so you can see that
we've again done a fairly decent job
with the slight trend towards some
over over segmentation for very high
cell members
and this is a part of a recent
publication
so in addition to immunohistochemistry
you've also worked a lot on
immunofluorescence
that of course allows you to expand the
number of species you're staining
however with additional technical
challenges of
dealing with secondary secondary
antibody cross reactivity
and analysis methods however
with multiple markers you both detect of
the
tissue that you're in as well as the
biomarker of interest and you can start
to perform
what i call tissue cytometry and then
of course this is much advanced with the
capabilities
introduced by imaging mass cytometry
we're now
using heavy metal labels we can identify
many many markers at once
however with again additional
complexities
around developing an appropriate
analysis methodology
to find the tumor regions and the cells
that you're looking for
so um as i mentioned imaging mass
cytometry uses
uh uh antibodies tagged with heavy metal
conjugates
um and uh rather and then
uh ablates these uh tissues
using a pulse laser um sending that
ablated uh
material through uh inductively coupled
plasmas in order to generate
a panel of images that relate to
individual biomarker spectrums
so at a high level why is imogen imc
analysis pipeline important
um the reason it's important is because
we need to have reproducible cell
identification
which will lead to more robust outputs a
very important consideration is how good
is good enough
for the segmentation and then what are
the specific goals of the analysis
do you need to worry more about cell
identification or
co-localization and of course i've
mentioned qc
as well you need to provide appropriate
metrics
for segmentation quality using the
advice
so our generalized imc analysis pipeline
follows a similar
flow with uh initially we receive the
imc panel text files we can convert
those to ome tiff files either using the
ncd viewer or using a
tool that we put up on our github that
will automatically convert them
and then there's two general approaches
to the analysis of these images
first we can take a computer vision
based approach
where we combine use a combination of
image
normalization and combination of
different channels to permit
us to do hierarchical tissue and cell
segmentation
the other approach is to take a machine
learning pixel classifier approach the
elastic cell profiler approach to
segmentation following this we can start
we can generate
additional information about a potential
neighborhoods and or different cell
types
and then from a classification
standpoint you can use either supervised
classification where you use scatter box
and grading strategies to determine your
your cell types or you can use
unsupervised methods of dimensional
error
reduction and clustering to be able to
reduce
to produce these results and then of
course
getting more numbers and quantitative
readouts and of course
incorporating this qc invalidation loop
in order to make sure that
you can go back and refine the results
you're getting from your segmentation
with the help of experienced trained
eyes
so there's some relative advantages of
these two of these two approaches
the nice thing about computer vision
based segmentation is that you can
actually tackle multiple different
tissue and cell types separately
as i'll discuss a bit more later and so
you can tune things however it
is longer and potentially more
challenging to implement such a strategy
for analysis versus with machine
learning pixel-based classification
you can learn from multiple different
images based on
annotations it might fail when there's
you know
maybe not a membrane present in some
regions and um
but it's currently primarily directed at
like one cell classifier trained for the
whole tissue
so that's the potential
of course the other limitation with imc
is that um
how do you look at 30 colors when your
eyes can see two maybe three colors
well um so one approach is to just
visualize multiple different regions
with different markers at once
as it's shown here um again with uh
computer vision based segmentation what
we can do is to
combine the stormal channels together to
identify
cellular from acellular stroma and then
layer in additional information from the
epithelium and potential
regions with no tissue in order to
generate a complete
picture of what's happening within that
tissue and
this is work done a number of years ago
in david hedley's lab at
uhn where we were able to work with him
to identify the different regions
segment
individual cells within each of these
regions and then probe those cells for
the presence of
various biomarkers and this was a
pancreatic cancer
and we're looking at platinum cisplatin
therapy is actually has a platinum
that happens to fall in the right mass
range for being able to detect directly
using emitting mass spectrometry and so
we did that we quantified the
presence of the platinum and what was
quite interesting to see
is that most of the platinum was
actually binding to the stromal regions
and not the tumors
cells although there was still binding
to the tumor cells and there was a lot
more in the stromal areas
that was uh that was something that you
know could only be detected with this uh
sort of approach uh in addition to
having um
this the this in this information
there's also a lot of
interesting embedded spatial information
in these in these images
so as i mentioned we do have individual
regions of interest uh
present on the uh tissue and then what
we
what we can do then is to start to look
at distance relationships
so this is a something indicating uh
distance a distance map showing distance
away from the
tumor stroma in these tumors versus
the intensity of a hypoxia marker in
these same tumors
so what's quite interesting to see there
is that um
you can see that the hypoxia marker
actually goes
uh increases in intensity the further
away you get from the strum
of course in tumors generally the stroma
is what blood vessels reside
likewise you see a corresponding
decrease in the proliferation
measured by two two independent
biomarkers um now
um this is this is a very interesting
result to obtain
however if you were doing this in
immunofluorescence you would have
already run out of
fluorophores to it wouldn't be able to
look at any other relationships but this
isn't the case with imaging mass
cytometry
again you've got any number of the other
biomarkers of interest
that you probe and this really becomes
quite a useful tool for hypothesis
generation to look at
the correlations between spatial
information present across multiple
tissues
so i'll speak briefly about another
project that i've done
in collaboration with dr jane garman in
her lab where she was looking
specifically at multiple sclerosis and
different lesions that
appear within multiple sclerosis
patients
and we did some initial segmentation
on this data and what we found was
actually poor segmentation
leads the bleed through of immune
markers uh resulting in poor
discrimination of certain cell types
so um you know whereas uh in general in
in tissues you don't get a lot of
mixed bt cells b and c
b cells and t cells um we did see that
mostly due to the pres the fact that
we're primarily using the dna
for the segmentation so this this
resulted in
challenges in interpretation so in order
to
address that we took a biologically
guided segmentation approach
so um we took the images and uh we
looked specifically for the presence of
particular biomarkers so
we sort of marched up this tree in
immunology
first looking for t cytotoxic from t
helper cells
by looking at the cells containing
either
cd3 alone or c3 plus cd8
we could then try we could then capture
those t
cells and then look for the presence of
potential b cells with
um the uh ig cap on lambda and then
finally
uh look for the remaining cell types
present in the tissue
with the corresponding dna content
with some expansion so what this allowed
us to do
in addition to this we also had a
immunologist
manually label particular cells that we
knew were of particular
classes with these labeled cells we
could then
take a classification approach where we
plot the various biomarkers against one
another
and we can use the manual labels to
actually identify
gates that would discriminate the
individual cell types
and this was done in pandas and so
this allowed us to interrogate
the proportion of these cells of a
number of different cell types within
these tissues
um we also have the spatial information
present in the in the image
and so um that's shown here in the
center there's blood vessel running
through the tissue section
um and so with the with all this
information we are able to generate a
spatial heat map
across where each panel column here is a
different
type of lesion and you can see the
activated lesions
tend to have a lot more of multiple
different immune cell types
than the normal brain and
in addition if we look at the average
distance to blood vessels
for each of these cell components what
you can see is that
in the active lesions with more cells
there's also a
lower distance of blood vessels for for
many of these
different immune populations indicating
that there might be more active
influx of the immune cells coming in
from the blood vessels
into this uh relation
in addition so this was based mostly off
of a
supervised strategy of course you can
also use
unsupervised classification using
ts and e to look at dimensionality
reduction followed by phenograph
uh where you classify each of these
cells into different clusters
um however uh if we go back to the
manual annotations that were made
um for the cells that can actually we
can plot those
within the tsme and that helps us to
actually identify
which cells are present and so we can
really take a mixed approach where we
could potentially label the major cell
classes we're interested in
and then find out you know vet use that
to validate um
whether particular phenograph um
clusters
relate to particular cell types um but
again with the with the
the large amount of uh different markers
that are present we could also
look at relationships that might be
discovered using clustering that we
might not necessarily know about ahead
of time
so that's uh hence the unsupervised
approach
so finally getting to quality control
again we've tried to take an approach of
using manual annotations to help us
identify where cells are
this was done in a particularly
challenging section this is a
mouse spleen where i'm showing a number
of
membrane markers and the reason i'm
showing them is that the actually the
dna
i'm staining didn't work quite well for
these markers and
once again if we get manual annotations
identifying kind of
the holes in the membrane signal that
might correspond to
the individual cells that are present
there
we can then take those annotations and
map them
across to a number of our different
segmentation strategies
so um so here's cell profile color and
the coloring is important here so um if
wherever you see
a green cell that's a one-to-one
correspondence between
the manual annotation and the presence
of a
cell on the tissue um when there's red
cells that means that there was under
segmentation so
there are um two manual annotations but
only one cell detected
and then uh wherever there are blue
cells that's where a the computer has
said that there's a cell there but there
was no manual annotation provided
and so using this we can start to
compare different strategies so this is
cell profiler in the middle here
this was kind of a customized you know
watershed based off of
uh computer vision um that uh
has fewer over over segmented cells and
then um
if you think about you know what's the
worst you can do for a cell
classification strategy
well that would be just overlaying a
five by five grid on across your whole
tissue and assuming each of those little
squares in the cell
and as as you can see that actually
doesn't do too bad of a job
except that it's not very very
biologically relevant and you
like might be missing on particular
tissues of interest
and so we can start to quantify these
these uh these different segmentation
algorithms and really come up with a you
know
what is the closest to the ground truth
that is the manual annotations
and as well as provide a mechanism to
try and improve this over time
so in conclusion um there's a very
strong need in immuno oncology to move
from one marker at a time towards a
multi-market strategy
to in order to obtain deeper molecular
profiling of cells and also
tissue level context tissue level
pathological assessment this way can
provide quantitative molecular
readouts at the single cell level of
course counting cells is quite tedious
and can be challenging to do accurately
so we work very closely with
pathologists try and build methods
to do this better and higher throughput
and then of course
hopefully it's come across that quality
control and segmentation
classification pipeline are very
important in order to be able to
validate the work that you're doing so i
just wanted to also
mention that i'm actually trying to work
on
developing a computational pathology
online resource where you can really
start to accumulate
all of the various strategies there's
been an explosive growth in the number
of different
segmentation classification strategies
as well as um
different image inputs pre-analytical
processing
all the way through control control
methods post-processing and statistical
bioinformatic analysis
so um that's the website is up there and
please let me know if you'd like to help
me in growing this resource and making
it more available
so with that i'd like to thank the
collaborators that i've been working
with
as well as my staff and thank you very
much
also to be the organizers for inviting
me
thank you dr mckee for that informative
presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's take a look dr mickey we
already have some great questions coming
in
could spatial relationships be explored
between discrete cell types
as well as tissue regions
um certainly yes any any way you can
divvy up the
image into regions and mark discrete
cell types uh
then you could certainly apply the same
sort of spatial mapping
to those cells as as you would to uh
to image regions thank you so much
what are your thoughts on alternative
methods
for single cell segmentation if the
nuclei based
alone is problematic
that's a great question so um and that's
actually something we ran into
um uh you know in this uh one study that
i mentioned
uh and i think you know uh some
certainly um uh taking advantage of uh
membrane um uh signal when that's
present
is um very useful and um uh and
one of the things that could be useful
along those lines is the new
segmentation
kit that i understand is available that
gives you a number of
membrane markers to help you
discriminate individual cell types
thank you so much and we have time for a
couple more questions regarding
the imaging data if i understand
correctly
that you converted image of tissue to
single cell data
and then performed tsne
please correct me if i'm wrong says an
audience member
um yes no that's exactly what we did was
to use
um segmentation to break the image which
is composed of pixels
up into regions composed of cells and
then we measure the average
intensity of all of the individual
markers in those cells
and then from there you have single cell
data that you can
feed through the rest of your analytical
pipelines as you could for
scitov data wonderful thank you
and could you talk a little bit about
how to normalize
the pixel intensity um that's a that's a
very good question
so um i think some of the information
might be present in that first
2016 paper where um what we did
was to actually uh look at both look at
the
background signal to um help to
normalize between batches of images
and then within single images you can
also
go with either your controls to get a
range of you know the positive and
negative to see the
max maximum
[Music]
range for any individual
channel and then you can use that to
also normalize
within channels if you want to start to
compare or combine channels to
two analysis thank you so much
and we have time for one more question
is it possible to measure the abundance
of a protein
at extracellular as well as
intracellular
level in the cell um
yes that is certainly possible as well
anything that you can label with
with an antibody you can detect using uh
imaging mass cytometry
and um the the only question there would
be how to deal with
um you know extracellular regions and
what what you want to necessarily
normalize the
the ultimate quantitate the ultimate
response
dr mckee before we move on to the next
presenter
first want to tell you thank you for
your time today and for this great
presentation did you want to add any
remarks before
you moved to dr amir um no
just uh thanks very much for the
opportunity to talk today and
i'm happy to talk to anyone over email
if that they have further questions
wonderful thank you so much again and
thank you for your important research
i now present our next speaker dr elod
david amir ceo of astrolab
diagnostics presenting on the topic of
developing an
analysis analysis pipeline for mass
cytometry studies
and for a complete biography on dr amir
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr amir welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
hey everyone i'm alad from astrolabe
diagnostics
and before i started the presentation i
would like to thank floydim for
inviting me to speak in today's virtual
webinar
and i would also like to thank you the
listeners for attending today
i know that many labs are reopening i
know the people are extremely busy
so i appreciate the fact that you took a
few minutes of your day
to listen into our webinar today i'm
going to talk about developing an
analysis pipeline for mass cytometry
studies
and the motivation here is the fact that
as you acquire your data as you're
working on your experiment
you're going to deal with a large number
of different algorithms
so i think that many researchers acquire
the data using the instrument
and then they deal with this many
different tools
there's disney there's flosam there's
the r programming language
all these different algorithms and
finding the uh
the path through all of these methods
can be quite daunting
so i would like to introduce a concept
called an analysis pipeline
and the idea of an analysis pipeline
doesn't come from
computational biology or bioinformatics
it actually comes from data science and
statistics
and the idea in this context is that you
acquire data
and you end up with what is essentially
a whole bunch of tables or numbers or by
axial plots
what you actually want is meaningful
biological insights some ideas
hypotheses or concepts
that you can use to promote your
research and
the analysis pipeline is exactly the
bridge
that fills that gap it is the series of
actions and protocols and methods
that you take to go from the raw data to
the biological insights so in the
context of
mass cytometry i think that the
different components of the analysis
pipeline are
pretty well established and essentially
you go through three major steps
the first one is cleaning the data
removing debris removing doublets
deeper coating then there's a step of
feature generation and in this stage you
take the raw data
and you can convert it into elements
that have some context
and have some meaning for example a very
common example
is uh cell subsets or
clusters and then finally you conduct
some sort of statistical analysis using
these features that you generated now
underlying all of these is a layer of
visualization
that helps you understand each one of
these steps
and the connections between them
so here are a few examples of protocols
and methods
that you might use in your analysis
pipeline for cleaning
people often use event length versus dna
or the gaussian parameters
or zebra coating then for future
generation i think that
one of the most popular methods is
traditional gating
where you identify canonical cell
subsets however you can also use
clustering
such as spade or flowsome or you can use
hyperspheres
and then for statistical analysis in
let's say increasing order of complexity
you can use a t-test
a logistic regression or some of the
fancier models like glm.net which are
available in the r programming language
finally for visualization some of the
common
methods people use include traditional
figures by excel plots and heat maps
or dimensionality reduction and these
include algorithms like umap or disney
now i'm going to provide an example
pipeline and
this pipeline comes from a paper that
was published by mount sinai
and the hipsie consortium a few years
ago
and this was an infectious disease study
it included 42 patients
and these patients uh each had two
different time points
acute and convalescent the goal of the
study
is to compare the structure of the
immune system between these two time
points
and you will notice that they used a
wide variety of assays they used rna
sequencing they used luminex
and finally they used mass cytometry
for the purpose of this presentation of
course we're going to focus on the last
one
and the use of the stuff so
what are the different tools that the
researchers used
how did they answer the questions under
each one of these rubrics
in their data so
for cleaning i actually just copied and
pasted a few lines from the methods
section of the paper
they used normalization beads they
identified cells based on dna
and event length and they remove dead
cells based on rhodium
103 so all of it pretty straightforward
and i think quite mainstream methods for
cleaning up your mass cytometry data
next for future generation and
dimensionality reduction they actually
used a series of algorithms
so the first thing they've done is they
took a subset
of the samples and they used traditional
gating
to identify major compartments there and
the major compartments the authors
identified are denoted here b cells
monocytes
c4 t cells and so on they then used a
logistic regression classifier
to extend these labels to all of the
other samples
so step one traditional gating step two
taking these labels
and applying them to other samples
then with each one of the canonical
subsets
they used unsupervised clustering
specifically they used the finograph
algorithm
finally they used metaclustering to
align these different clusters
since each sample each fcs file
was clustered separately it was required
to use another
metaclustering step to align them so
a bit of a complex process but at the
end of it
they ended up with about 25 or 30
clusters
that started from the canonical cell
subsets b cells t cells and so on
and broke them down
finally for the statistical analysis
they used a pretty straightforward
approach they looked at fault changes
and they looked at p values using a
t-test
so what you're seeing here is one of the
money shots or money figures from the
paper
and in this figure the x-axis are the
different
is the different clusters that the the
authors identified
and the y-axis is the full change
between the acute
and convalescent time points
specifically
the red bars the positive numbers the
note that the given subset was more
frequent
in the acute time point and you can see
multiple subsets
that are related to innate immunity for
example the double positive monocytes
and the cd14 mos
positive monocytes then the negative
values to your left
denote that the frequency in the
convalescent time point
was higher than the acute time point and
we're seeing multiple cells for the
adaptive immune response there
such as different t cells and b cells
finally you can see the log 10 of the p
values at the top
denoted in purple so this was a pretty
brief summary of
the decisions these authors made you're
welcome to
look at the paper for the details if we
go back to
this slide we can slot in the
different methods they used so for
cleaning event like versus dna and
rhodium
for future generation traditional gating
phenograph and meta clustering
for statistical analysis fall change and
t-test
and then for visualization traditional
figures and t-sne for dimensionality
reduction
as you design your experiment as you
think
about your data acquisition you build
your panel you
decide on your protocol i encourage you
to think of these rubrics as another
aspect
of your of your work of your project and
if you decide on these even before
acquiring the data
i think you will be much better equipped
for the analysis step once you have the
data once you have the fcs files
so i'm actually going to address a few
common questions that come up
uh when deciding on the different
algorithms that you would like to use
and let's start with clustering
clustering is the idea where that
that is the idea where you group objects
so that
objects in the same group are similar to
each other in this case
an object is one cell or one event
in an fcs file the similarity
is the distance across all channels and
the groups are what we call clusters and
ideally
we would like to correspond to canonical
cell subset
so all a clustering algorithm does is
convert
distances between cells into these
different groups
and there are a lot of these algorithms
in the literature
there's dozens of different clustering
algorithms available
and as you read through them i think
that it is helpful to
try to characterize them according to a
taxonomy
and three parameters three questions you
can ask yourself
is are one what is the underlying math
of a given algorithm two what are the
parameters you as the user need to
decide on
when running that parameter and three
how can you technically run the
algorithm
if you read the paper that's nice but
you actually need to bring the method to
your data
a common answer is you can run some you
can run some r code
however for most users some sort of
graphical user interface
is preferred so let's examine a few
common algorithms
uh the first one is flossim and flossam
was published
in 2015 by van gaasenet l
it's built on another clustering
algorithm called self-organizing maps
and just very briefly a self-organizing
map is a neural network
and these are the same neural networks
you might read about in the news in the
context of deep learning
but while deep learning attempts to
classify data
um the neural network in the
self-organizing maps is
unsupervised it doesn't attempt to
classify anything it's looking for
structure
and this nice animation from wikipedia
actually gives a good idea
of how self-organizing maps work you
have this lattice
off of different points or vertices
and these vertices are attracted
iteratively
to centers of mass in your data so
initially the grid
is just a square and then over multiple
iterations different points get
attracted to
the centers of population the critical
parameter for flowsome
is the number of clusters that you're
going to indicate and specifically
the the width and height of this lettuce
that you see here which are called x-dim
and y-dim
and when you run the algorithm the
number of clusters you ask for
is the number of clusters you're going
to get so it leads to a bit of an open
question of
how many of these clusters do i need and
i'm actually going to touch on it in a
few minutes
flowsome is available through cytobank
through flojo
and through other software packages as
well
so it's pretty straightforward to run
the second algorithm is called
phenograph and it is using
a method called the vein method what
phenograph does
is convert the data into a k nearest
neighbor's graph in other words
the first step of the algorithm is to
tell each cell
which are the five or ten most similar
cells
to that cell and the idea is that the
algorithm is looking for highly
connected groups
in other words we're looking for clumps
of cells
that see each other that we tell them
that they're similar to each other
the critical parameter for phenograph is
the number of neighbors or k
and just as a rule of thumb the more
neighbors you provide the higher k
the less clusters you're going to get so
with flosstum you clearly indicate how
many clusters you want
with phenograph you indicate these
number of neighbors
phenograph is available as a flowjo
plugin it's also available as an r
package called site of kit and that
package includes a graphical user
interface
so there is no need to write any code
one last algorithm is called xshift and
this one comes from the gary nolan group
and this is a graph density
density-based clustering algorithm
you'll notice that the first step here
convert data into a k-nearest neighbors
graph
is the same one as phenograph and that
goes back to the taxonomy i mentioned
before
in this case there is quite a lot of
overlap in the math
underlying phenograph and x-shift while
phenograph is looking for
connected components x-shift is looking
for centroids
in other words it is looking for a
representative
of the given clusters the t cell which
is the t
cell of them all and is most connected
to all the other t
cells once again the critical parameter
the number of neighbors k
and once again higher the k the lower
the number of clusters
xshift is available through a software
package called vortex and also as a
flowjob plugin
so which clustering algorithm do you
should you use
and thankfully there's been two
benchmarks one of which is cited here
that took these different algorithms and
ran them
on a set of different sites of data sets
so what you're seeing here are two of
these data sets to the left
the levine 32 dimension data set which
was more broad
has a large number of different cell
subsets to the right
the mos men rare data set where the
researchers will try to identify
one specific rare populations
in each of these figures you see
different clustering algorithms
including flowsome
and um and vortex
and uh in exchange sorry about that and
the x-axis is a metric called the f1
score
the higher it is the more concordant the
algorithm results
with the traditional gating for these
data sets
and just by looking at these you will
notice that
flossam and xshift rate
pretty well in both of these different
data sets
in other words based on this benchmark
whether you're looking for
a wide variety of different data sets or
looking for a specific career population
it looks like these two markers perform
pretty well
now to clarify these other algorithms
listed here
also have their use also have their
utility however when you first reach a
new data set when you're asking yourself
which of these 20 something algorithms i
should run
i would strongly recommend you start
with either flossam or xshift
they seem to work pretty well and these
results have been validated
in another benchmark as well
another common question is what about
batch effects and
these algorithms are built to identify
similarities
and by extension differences in the data
and batch effect
is a pretty strong uh trend that these
algorithms will detect
to illustrate this i'm looking at a data
set that was generated by brian sellers
in the national institutes of health
and this is a toy example we have one
donor the panel only has five markers
and the purpose of these markers
is to identify different types of cd4 t
cells
we have five different samples and they
have artificial batch effects that were
introduced by titration
so what you're seeing here is the level
of city four
across these five samples and as the
dilution goes up the separation of city
four increases as well
what happens when we take these data
sets
so i combined all the five samples and i
clustered them
using flowsome i set the number of
clusters to 16
and what i'm expecting are six different
cell subsets we're looking at cd3
negative
which is linear negative in this case
we're looking for cd4 negative t cells
and then the four different t-cell
populations
so what you see here is a heat map
with the um the results the 16 different
clusters and the intensity of every
marker in each one of these clusters
and what we're looking at here are two
different clusters that seem to
correspond to a spectrum memory c4t
cells so they're positive for cd4
there's positive for cd3
they're negative for cd45ra and c07
now if we look at the distribution of
these clusters
across the different samples we will see
that two of these samples
have many more cells in cluster two
while three
other samples have many more cells in
cluster one
if this was a typical experiment we
might suspect uh that there is some sort
of biological trend here however since
we know that these are different
dilutions
and this is the same donor the same
sample essentially
we can safely say that what we're seeing
here is just the batch effect
the reason we're seeing two different
clusters is a combination of
the different patches and the fact that
we asked flossam for 16 different
clusters
so we're going to get these 16 clusters
so please be mindful of best effects as
you cluster your data
and there's different algorithms that
can help you normalize the data you're
welcome to look into that
another approach is the one that was
presented
in the paper i've shown you before with
chicken gunia where you can cluster each
sample separately
and then you can cluster the clusters or
meta cluster
and i included three papers here that
follow this approach the type two
full disclosure and the first author on
them
the third author the third paper came
out just last month
and it includes a meta clustering
approach as well
so again be mindful of patch effects you
can either correct them using a batch
correction algorithm
or you can use the math clustering
approach
so once again i would like to highlight
this framework
when you think about running your
experiment just go over these rubrics
and ask yourself
how am i going to clean the data how am
i going to identify different features
whether they're
cell subsets or clusters through
unsupervised clustering
what's the parameters i need to deal
with for example the number of clusters
for flossam
or the number of neighbors for
phenograph
and finally how am i actually going to
take these results and
analyze them using a statistical test at
the end of the day you want some sort of
significant score or fall change that
you can report
in your paper one last note
if you need any help with any of these
questions astrolabe offers a fully
standardized
analysis pipeline for your site of data
the way apple astrolabe works is you
upload your fcs files
we take you through all of these steps
pre-processing
subject labeling and also fulfilling the
role of the bios distinction
and doing the follow-up analysis
analysis takes just a couple of hours
and then you can start navigating
through the results and
get the kind of figures that we've seen
over this presentation
fall changes comparisons plus
quantification and significance and
everything
so if you do find yourself getting stuck
on
any of these steps if you need help
please reach out to us
and with this i'm going to thank you
again for attending this webinar i'm
going to
thank floydim for organizing and for
inviting me i'm alad you can reach me at
el astrolabediagnostics.com and at this
point i'm happy to answer any questions
that come up from the audience
dr ramirez thank you for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the
q a live portion of this webinar if you
have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left
of your screen so let's take a look we
already have some questions coming in
do you have any preference between
t s and e and umap
how do i know which one to use
so that's uh that's a very common
question and there seems to be
an very lively debate in the community
on how to decide between these two
methods
to be honest uh they're pretty similar
to each other
and while there are mathematical
differences
and sometimes the figures look different
i think for most intents and purposes
they lead to similar results
i would just pick the one that is more
comfortable for you to use i will point
out that
if you do go for disney then there is a
more modern implementation called opsni
which is available as for the flow joe
and also as an art package
and and if you go for umap
then actually if you go for either
method i recommend you try writing it a
couple of times just to make sure that
you get a figure that looks nice but
apart from that really pick the one that
is easier for you to use
thank you so much doctor and how do you
go about performing
preliminary supervised clustering and
then use
that to perform unsupervised clustering
i'm guessing that question refers to
astrolabe
however it can actually become part of
any analysis pipeline
when you cluster the data there's
there's no
there's no law there's no part of the
constitution that says you can only use
one algorithm
with every data set and
when you do some sort of future
generation whether it's traditional
gating or clustering
then you know which one of these
populations
each cell ended up with so you can layer
another another algorithm or another
method
on top of that just using astrolabe as
an example
we have one step that identifies
canonical populations
and then we have a second step that
allows you to cluster on top of them
likewise going to the
the paper i gave as an example the
chicken gunia paper
they used a semi-supervised method to
find populations
and then they cluster within each one of
these populations
i think that you probably can do it with
something like cytobank or flowjo but
if you're a bioinformatician or access
to r it's relatively
straightforward to do thank you so much
i want to thank our audience members for
these great questions coming in
what is your preferred approach for
estimating when setting the number of
clusters and populations
that's unfortunately a bit of an open
problem when it comes to clustering
and it comes up in any context in which
you use one of these algorithms
whether it's biology or machine vision
or
if you're running a marketing firm and
you want to cluster your
the page views on your website and um
there are
different thresh there's different
heuristics you could use like aic
and bic sadly they don't seem to work
very well in the context of single cell
data
so i would say start with
the number of populations you expect to
find
and you design the panel so you have
some broad idea of what is supposed to
be in there
and then attach some multiplier to it
and work from there
so if you're expecting to find let's say
20 different populations
i would try 40 clusters you could also
try different
runs and it's going to be more time
consuming but
it does increase the chance you're going
to get the clusters that you need
so for example using the same using the
same numbers
if you're expecting about 20 populations
i would try
40 60 and 80. review the heat maps
review the results
pick the one that makes the most sense
to you
thank you so much and we have time for a
couple of more questions
do you find the batch effect corrections
are enough to remove the batch effects
that's a tricky question because we
don't know what's the batch effect
to begin with it is not quantified we we
assume it's there
but we can't really know what it's going
to be
and to the best of my knowledge there
aren't any
papers that actually built a benchmark
for that
so all of the manuscripts that developed
batch correction methods they're using
some biological data set they have a
biological question
and they're trying to assess the best
effect even though
it was not built into the experiment
based on my experience and based on the
several hundred data sets i've seen i i
strongly suspect that normalization is
probably not enough and
it comes with two with two questions
the first one is did we identify
all of the batch effect did we remove
all of it or at least
a significant portion correctly and then
if we mirror that question how much of
the real biological signal
did we lose due to the batch correction
method
and this was actually quantified pretty
well with single cell rna sequencing
and from there we know that methods uh
have a tendency to remove quite a lot of
the biological variation as well
so i would be very careful with
the batch effect methods that you're
using and
and always remember that there is a
biological question
underlying your experiment try to focus
on that and build
in reverse wonderful thank you so much
and we have time for one more question
and this next audience member says great
presentation a lot
what is the difference between
semi-supervised clustering and
unsupervised clustering and it's a
two-part question what feature could
determine which cluster i need
so that's uh that's a bit tricky because
there's the definitions that come from
machine learning the official
definitions and there's the kind of
terms that people
in the bioinformatics and biology
community
have adopted so in machine learning
there's two big categories
one is unsupervised learning
which is where clustering usually falls
and in unsupervised
learning we don't know what's the labels
of the data
so in the case of scitaf we don't know
in advance
what's the different categories what's
the different populations the other
major group of clusters of algorithm is
supervised learning
where we have the labels and
we know what we're looking for we're
training on a well-labeled data set and
then we're applying that to
our raw data semi-supervised
the definition falls in between and
it's a bit of a fluid definition i think
that in the context of
bioinformatics and in the context of the
site of people use
semi-supervised to denote a clustering
algorithm that has some biological
knowledge within it
and um there's there's a few that does
do this
they're also often referred to as
automated getting algorithms
and i would say that more often than not
you should probably stick to
unsupervised clustering
the problem is that the same supervised
methods
usually require quite a bit of work to
uh to get you the results that you
expect and assessing whether they're
successful or not
is quite challenging so
i would say stick to the unsupervised
methods look at the heat maps and decide
how to label your data
and of course if you need help with this
process please reach out
i'm ella at as2labdiagnostics.com and
i'm always happy to advise on a specific
experiment
dr ramirez this has been a great
presentation and we really appreciate
your time would you like to provide any
final remarks for the audience before we
move to the next presentation
just to reiterate my comments from the
beginning of the talk thank you everyone
for attending
these are crazy times and there's a
deluge of
webinars out there i really appreciate
the fact that you've chosen to take your
afternoon to uh to tune in so thank you
for your time
and thank you again for your time for
today and for your important research
and i now present our last speaker dr
rafael
pitardo from the oren edson foundation
endowed chair and the scientific
director at the translational data
science integrated research center and
the fred hutchinson cancer research
center
presenting on the topic of fost a new
interpretable machine
leaning approach for automated gating
for a complete biography
of dr gatardo please visit the biography
tab at the top
of your screen dr katardo welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
well thanks very much for the
introduction so i am pleased to tell you
about some of the work that we've been
doing in my lab
and what we believe to be a
transformative new approach for site of
data analysis
so first let me um you know disclose a
few partnerships that we've had with
industry so today
thanks to great advances in cytometry
like scitov
and multi-spectral flow we can now
quantify the joint expression of
up to 50 proteins at the single cell
level and that's just growing
despite this manual analysis is still
the gold standard
so it might be okay to be usual to
visualize you know a handful of proteins
but assuming that a cell can express or
not express a certain protein
there's a huge combination or a huge
number of combinations that we can
explore right think about this if you
have 20 proteins and
each protein can be on enough you have 2
to the 20
combinations which are millions if you
have 30 it's billions right and think
about 40 it's even more than that
so these not only doesn't scale actually
lead to
biased results because oftentimes you
only sort of explore part of the pay the
space that you think is important
so what ends up at the end is that
critical information is left on the
table
we know that immune responses are really
diverse
right and so what if we could actually
use this high dimensional data to
understand this diversity and how it
relates to treatment efficacy
what if what we cared about involved
maybe a new combinations of multiple
markers or proteins
expressed in a few cells something that
maybe we didn't know about
right certainly something that wasn't
deemed important acrylic
so here's an example right here's an
example of cells that might be very
important that express
these combinations maybe maybe those
were not really part
of your you know gating scheme that you
define a priori
so this is where our approach excels
we're going to explore the data in a
totally unbiased way
looking at all combinations without
necessarily
looking at i priori specifically defined
subsets
okay so you know obviously the the
approach is a bit complicated but i'm
going to try to quickly walk you through
the algorithm for identifying cell
populations
in a totally unbiased way ensuring full
exploration of cytometry data
so my group has actually been working on
this problem for many many years you
know
at least 10 years if not 15. and it's
taken
us a lot of time to really understand
the technology how we should approach
the data and how we should explore the
data and we finally
feel that we have something that you
know
we hope will transform the world of
cytometry analysis
so as you will see it actually borrows a
lot of idea from manual analysis because
when people explore the space through
manual analysis they know a lot of
things about the data so they're doing
that in a way that makes a lot of sense
given the technology
but we actually use principal
statistical methods and computers to do
the work
so here's an example we're looking at t
cells and so
t cells express cd3 and so they're going
to be positive for
you know that marker for cd3 and now
they might be expressing all sorts of
other markers some t cells will be cdh
positive
some of these cells might express cd28
cd69 pd1 and so on so forth right
so here's an example of a cell that
expressed cd3 cd8 pd1
cd28 and cd69 and therefore
you can see that they are on the right
because they are positive for these
markers
now if we look at cells that maybe do
not express cd28
that intensity for that marker will be
on the left hand side will be on the
negative range of the data
and so we can actually use binary trees
to explore the space of protein
coexpression again
very similar to what is done in a manual
analysis and we can
annotate all the cells in a given data
set so in this example we start with t
cells then we label them as cd8 negative
cd8 positive then we look at another
marker in this case pd1
right and we label p1 positive p1
negative
so in reality of course the data do not
really look like these these are
cartoons right the reality is that the
data are more variable if you're looking
at cyto if you tend to have more of a
peak around zero
because it's pretty good there's no you
know compensation issues but it tends to
have more skewness in the data
and so we actually use you know again
statistical methodology to help us do
that and we use non-parametric density
estimations meaning that we can actually
apply that to scitov or regular
cytometry and we use something called
the tat string
estimator to find the optimal cut point
the optimal separation between positive
and negative populations
and of course you know this idea can be
extended to more than two levels of
expression we can automatically explore
one two three or four modes of
expression and infer the right number
based on the data so it's fully
data driven so in this example i'm
showing you we've done the same
exercises but in fact maybe we've
identified three levels of expression
for pd1
pd1 negative p1 dim and pd1 bright
so we actually do that for all
combinations
of four proteins and i will explain why
we're doing four proteins later
but this is important because we want to
look at all the different combinations
so if you think about manual gating
oftentimes you know the operator will
sort of gate specific population
in a given order maybe they'll start
with their lymphocytes and then the cd3
and then cd4 and cd8 and then maybe
other markers down the road
but the order is kind of important and
maybe by you know sort of restricting
this the search path into specific order
maybe you're missing some structure in
the data
and so we're looking at all combinations
of four proteins
all the different colors in different
orders this is critical because we
really don't want to miss structure in
the data we limit it to four
because as i told you the space is huge
so if we want to look at all
combinations we can't really do that
even computers cannot really explore you
know a billion trees
so we have to restrict the search space
and this is okay here because we're only
trying to do that to find
the sort of cut points and where we find
separation between
the different levels of expression so
that we can annotate the cells
so we call we actually call this the
annotation for us because we're building
a forest of trees and it's used to
define the cell level annotations
so why is this important so let's let's
just look at a simple example this is
actually you know i told you a cartoon
but this is actually came up in a real
data analysis where we're trying to get
ccr7 if you look at the expression
profile of ccr7
it kind of looks like you know unimodal
expression with a long tail
and so from a point of view of a data
driven approach it's very hard to know
where is the separation between the
positive and negative populations
however in that example if we were to
condition cd8
right so first we look at cd8 positive
cells and among those we look at ccr7
then we find structure
right so once we have conditioned the cd
cd8 expression we can actually identify
the structure in the data
and this idea is so important to
actually identify proteins that are
informative
because if we um export all the proteins
across all these trees
in that forest and there's a marker
that's never um
never have if it never has evidence of
multi-modality
maybe we shouldn't really be using it
maybe it's due to poor staining
uh it's a not a very good antibody or
maybe it's not really
a marker or protein that uh exhibit
multi modality maybe it's a functional
marker right and so we can model it in a
different way downstream
okay so now that i told you that we
stopped at four proteins
because we can really enumerate all the
trees if we were to look at more than
four protein if we're really to use all
the 40 or 50 proteins
well this the step that i just described
would just define these cut points and
to be able to
know which cells are positive or
negative for a given marker but in the
end we really want to
annotate the cells given all the
different combinations and so we can
actually
build these trees but maybe we can just
select a few of them so we actually
randomly sample a large number of what
we call these full depth
trees to find our populations of
interest
and for those of you who know a little
bit about machine learning this is kind
of analogous to what you would do
when you do decision trees and you use
something called boosting or bagging or
your sort of average of a number of
trees
so we want in this case we're doing this
across you know maybe hundreds of
thousands of trees and we want to
identify the populations
that are robust and consistent across
these trees
and samples because we do that for each
sample so we can actually compare that
across samples as well
so i'd like to clarify one thing is that
we're not just doing boolean gating
we're really trying to identify
populations that are robust and
in a way we're sort of doing something
called unsupervised variable selection
we're selecting the variables that we
think are important because if you were
to do boolean gating again
you go back to the original problem we
have you know billions of combination
billions of populations you can redo
that
in our case through that we typically
end up with hundreds of populations who
are sort of really narrowing down to
things that we believe are truly
important
so in this example we have these you
know different trees
and what you will see is that if you
look at these three sort of
uh populations right so if you look at
these trees this is
a population at the end that's a
population that's a powerful relation
these are not exactly the same because
the path
is different in each case but you can
see that the combinations of colors is
the same so you actually
arrive at a phenotype that is very
similar and so in this case we see it
oftentimes across these trees so we know
it's consistent we know it's important
and we record it so that's kind of the
idea behind the algorithm
so some of the key features and by the
way i'm giving you a link to the
preprint here we're actually
just about to upload a new version so
you'll see a new version soon there
but this will take you to that new
version uh eventually so
some key features algorithm leads to
biologically interpretable results
why because the way we define the
population we know exactly whether the
cells are you know cd3 positive or
negative cd4 negative
positive and so on and so forth so we
get sort of a complete phenotypes
based on the markers again very similar
to what we get through manual gating
this is important also because it allows
us to do sample level processing so we
can actually
analyze each sample independently and
then because we have the phenotypes we
have the label of the population we can
just compare it
across the analysis of all the other
samples right
something that's not possible with other
algorithms
and oftentimes what you have to using
these other tools
you kind of have to collapse all of the
data and once you do that
if there's any sort of technical
variability or batch effects
you get a big smudge and you don't get
very good um
definition of your populations so again
there's more details in our paper but i
think these are very important and i'll
try to highlight that again in the
application later on
our algorithm is actually a little bit
more um computationally demanding
and um i'll show that we have a very
good sort of
cloud implementation on the next line so
i told you that it's actually
working pretty well against our
competing approaches
so we've done lots of simulation to try
to look at you know how well the
our algorithm performs compared to let's
say flowsome or phenotype that are
really good algorithms that have
been built by other groups so we
actually simulated data um to mimic
scitov so sort of a
you know a spike at zero maybe more
heavy tail
we've done also something similar to
cytometry and all of that in the paper
so what we've tried to do is using these
data whether it's ground truth to see
how well do we recover the true number
of clusters so the true number of
populations in the sample
and how well do we classify the cell so
the plot on the left hand side so to
show you
the estimated number of clusters versus
the true number
and what you would want is an algorithm
that's on the line y equal
x because it tells you that it's
perfectly estimated the true number of
clusters
and that sort of magenta color that you
see here is is our approach
fast and you can see that other
algorithms do very
performs very poorly trying to estimate
the true number of population
and this is the cell level
classification accuracy trying to
accurately classify each cell to their
known phenotype and again we do very
very well here
okay so i told you that you know this is
a little bit more computationally
demanding so we built a really
good cloud enabled pipeline using next
floor this runs on aws
we can actually process a lot of um
samples
because i told you we actually process
samples in parallel
so we can do that very efficiently and
we've run data sets with as many as you
know four
thousand um cyto fcs files
okay let me use a real example and again
you know i'll sort of
try to stress that at the end but this
is a real example where
we've applied fast we identify a
biomarker correlated
a biomarker of responses to
immunotherapy that no other approaches
could identify
so this is looking at more call cell
carcinoma it's a rare but increasing
skin cancer in the us it's actually very
aggressive
it's twice as likely to metastasize as
melanoma
up until recently it's been very
difficult to treat
these things have changed a little bit
with
sort of checkpoint therapy and
antipedia1 and immunotherapy
historically only 10 of patients
survived three years after studying
chemotherapy
so we've actually been very lucky to be
working with our collaborators at the
hedge and the university of washington
including pauline who's an expert in
merkel sarcar cinema
and who was involved in the trial that
led to the approval of anti-pity one for
merkel cell
so i told you marcos has really
transformed treatment if you look at
this is an example of the patient that
was seen as part of the
pulse clinic what you can see is that
this is the baseline measurement
right you can see the tumor that sort of
circled and
only three weeks after one dose of
pembrolizumab and type 21
the tumor is completely gone so it's
amazingly fast
and it works really really well
unfortunately it doesn't work for
everybody
so if you look actually at the fda fda
press release
and if you read that this is actually
the press release of citn09 the trial
that led to the approval of that drug
that was run
by the cancer immunotherapy trial
network at the federation
only 5 25 have a complete response rate
so
it's good but it's not great
so what we wanted to do is work with our
colleagues
at the citn to try to understand you
know the lack of response
why some people respond better than
others so we approached them because we
felt like we had a transformative
computational framework for cytometry
data and because they are part of the
immune immune monitoring center that
collected
all of the data as part of this trial we
felt like would be nice to work with
them
and maybe analyze or realize some of the
data that were generated
when we approach them they say well this
is fantastic we love to work with you
but just to let you know you know we've
looked at the data and there's no signal
so nonetheless we decided to give it a
shot and try to see if we could
identify baseline predictors or
responses to antipediment therapy
so in our case we were you know
interested in analyzing the t
cell panel this is actually a cytometry
data set but i'll show you some site of
data
on some of the next slides we wanted to
identify these baseline t-cell
predictors of anti-pedia one of
responses to antipede one so baseline
before they receive
any treatment so we actually run fast
and fast discovered 230 total phenotypes
out of these 125 were cd3 positive so
125 were t cell phenotypes because we
wanted to focus on the t cell aspect for
now
given the way the drug works we
just look at the cd3 positive phenotypes
four we're actually significantly
associated with response
even after bonferroni multiple testing
correction which is very conservative we
identify
two cd4 phenotypes and two cda
phenotypes i'm going to focus on the cd8
if you want to know more this
about the cd4 you can look at the paper
but the phenotypes are actually very
consistent across the two
so these actually um gives you the
phenotype here
so there's the two phenotypes the cd8 uh
in each case there's one that's actually
a pd1 dim and a pd1 bright
so there's sort of two different level
of expression of pd1
so these are cda t cells that express
hladr that express
pd1 either demobrite and that express
cd28
what we see is that at baseline there's
a much higher frequency
of these cells and the responders
and obviously the algorithm does not
know anything about the clinical trial
or you know anti pd1 but what we found
is that
if you had a frequency of t cells that
express pd1 in blood
and baseline you're more likely to
respond so it kind of makes sense
because anti-pd1 is actually blocking
pd1
it's releasing the break on these t
cells and therefore the
um volunteers are more likely to respond
in this case right
however this was not identified by
manual gating because they only looked
at pd1 but what was important here was
combination of hladr
cd28 and p1 combination that was never
looked at
manually we have additional data where
we looked at correlating some of these
measurements in blood what was
measured in the tumor we looked at p1
staining tcr clonality
we got really correlation that made us
feel pretty good about what we're seeing
this being said we wanted to try to
validate these bar markers so
we asked a collaborator to go back to
the study and see if they can pull out
more samples so they had actually frozen
pbmc
samples to see if we could validate that
and in fact we did
so they they generated more data from
the sim study based on measurements
and again we find that there's a good
separation and a significant
association of that exact same phenotype
with clinical response
we wanted to do more validation so we
looked at the literature if we could
find
maybe some publicly available data sets
and we did find one that was actually a
study that was done at stanford using
scitov
where they looked at anti-pd1 for
melanoma
and we were lucky enough that all of our
markers were a subset of their cytok
data set so we run our approach
and again we found a good significant
association
of that baseline measurement with
response
the separation is not as clear in this
case because it's a different technology
or maybe it's a different cancer but
it's still
significantly associated with response
so we've you know we have two examples
of validation of the study and we have
many many other examples where we've
applied this approach and we identify
you know significant cholesterol
response in the context of car t cells
autoimmune disease infectious diseases
and so forth
so let me briefly show you another
example that will highlight some of the
benefits of our approach this is looking
at myeloid cells in the context of
again pd1 in this case this is actually
the work of creator all that newt cytov
and show that they identify sort of a
monocyte subset
advanced noun that was correlated with
responses to antipedia one melanoma
we run fast on their data set and we
identify pretty much the exact same
predictor in this case there's actually
two batches
so uh we stratified like that so batch
one and batch two
non-responders responders so the
responders are the higher frequency of
these monocytes at baseline so again we
basically reproduce these results
we're generally getting a slightly
different phenotypes because we
utilize all the markers we get something
a little bit more refined
we looked at two other data sets we
analyze citn9 because we also had a
myeloid panel we
analyzed another citm data set it's
actually a vaccine trial for
immunotherapy and again so similarly we
identify
these monocytes that express cd14 that
are negative for cd-16 and nhlerg
upright that were correlated with
response
now in the initial study you know the
authors actually focused
on these phenotype that i showed you
here for a couple of reasons because
they
you know couldn't really identify the
true phenotype because i told you most
algorithms don't give you a true
phenotype so they had to
you know um restrict it to something
they could understand and then validate
by facts
and so we've actually rerun our
algorithm on their facts panel and again
we get a perfect separation
but something that's kind of interesting
because fast give you specific labels
and phenotypes we can actually
also aggregate the exact same phenotypes
we can marginalize over other markers
and we did that and we again you know
using the exact same phenotype that
they've described we see the separation
in the two trials that i showed you in
the previous slide maybe it's not as
good as or the biomarkers we identify
using fast because maybe the other
markers are important
but we can still sort of validate what
they had published
what i love about that is that it shows
you that we have sort of the best words
between
you know where we do fully uh automated
unbiased discovery
and something that's more targeted where
we can sort of marginalize and group
populations of interest
we can also therefore multibyte analysis
of groups of populations similar to
what's been done in the field of gene
expression analysis through
something called genset enrichment
analysis here we can use the phenotypes
that are derived by fast
to grow populations of interest for
example you can say let me model
all the t cells that have some sort of
an exhausted phenotype and we can do
multivariate modeling very easily so a
lot of cool stuff we can do
with the annotations that we get from
the algorithm
so you know obviously this work would
have been possible without all great
collaborators and funders
and if you want to learn more go to the
following url or
feel free to shoot me an email i'd be
happy to talk to you about it thanks
very much for your time
thank you dr guitardo for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
our webinar if you have any questions
you want to ask
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we already have some questions coming in
for you as well
i can see that you've presented results
on both cytometry
and scitov how does your method adapt to
each data type
yeah thank you thanks for that question
um so actually it adapts pretty well
because the way we've designed it we
don't really make any assumption about
the data that we're working on
we actually use something that's called
a non-parametric statistical method
so from that point of view it's actually
very flexible it can work with
any kinds of data whether it's cytometry
or cytosk
um and and you know as i've shown we can
get really good results and consistent
results so we can actually compare
things that were generated
on irregular flow cytometry to recite of
which is great sometimes for doing
validation
or cross study integration or
comparisons
i can't hear you
i apologize and does your method work
even
in the presence of batch effects
yeah so that's another great question so
um ella david talked about that a little
bit that if you have batch effects if
you have you know multiple runs and
samples that will run at different times
sometimes you really have to be very
careful because you can see a lot of
variation
into the data that you're looking at um
and so
you know he's talked a little bit about
one way to
correct for that is to use sort of a
batch method removal techniques where
you try to align things
and those can work pretty well but
sometimes it's a little bit difficult to
know
whether you've really removed the patch
effect and potentially you could
actually remove some true biological
variation which is something we've seen
in some data sets
so in our case we don't actually do that
because each sample
is analyzed independently and so from
that point of view when we analyze each
sample
it's part of its own batch and then we
call the population and we know their
labels we know exactly what they are
so we can we can compare them across
samples so in a way
it already accounts for the batch
automatically and it sort of gives you
the results that are really sort of
badge corrected
thank you very much and how could an
application of foss to
pbmc samples from kubin19 patients
be particularly beneficial and this is a
two-part question
can you picture what sort of questions
would be good to address
with fast in this case so i would say
yes so there's a couple of reasons one
is obviously because there's a lot of
interest there's lots of data that's
been generated so there's a lot of
hypotheses that have actually
already been generated so in this case
you could potentially
come with your hypothesis that you've
you know generated already maybe looking
at prior data sets
and then sort of analyze it and quickly
see do i see that in my data because as
i said
when we apply fast we know exactly what
we're getting so if you said
show me all the t cells that express you
know pd1 in our case
we can go that we can analyze the data
fish it out and give you that answer
at the same time you might want to do
discovery because there's still a lot
that we don't know about covet and what
it does to the immune system for example
so we could sort of go at it from an
unbiased point of view and just trying
to see
what we're finding and potentially what
correlates with disease outcome or
disease severity
and the last one that i'll make which is
something that i've shown in my
presentation again it's
it's it's a very powerful approach for
combining and integrating data
even if they are generated on different
platforms so that's something that i
think could be very valuable in fact
we've started to do some of that in my
lab
so to collect data sets that have been
published
and i really encourage everyone who's
been doing that using coveted studies
that have access to foster medicine to
share those publicly because i think
this would really advance science
and we're working on those and we've
already contacted some authors actually
in trying to realize some data and
integrate some of the data sets
dr gottaro these are great questions
coming in and i want to thank our
audience again for their participation
does foster require a minimum number of
samples
yeah that's another great question
because i told you it's a per sample
um sort of processing and so you have to
think about the fact if you have just
one sample
you know you can analyze it but we still
even though we analyze the sample
independently
there's a lot of things that we require
in terms of saying
if we see a population is this real do
we trust it so we kind of look at the
consistency across samples sort of
talked a little bit about that during
the presentation
so there's no hard number but i would
say rule of thumb is i would say at
least 15 samples because you
you know that would give you enough
confidence that what you're seeing is
real
uh but we've actually analyzed these
studies that have you know as few as 10
samples
now regarding foss can you do us a favor
and compare it to other clustering
methods like flusam or
phonography yeah so so we've done that
compensation flow sum of phenograph
um and you know we have we have a paper
online
and you know we've done some new
simulation actually doing new
comparisons so that you know they are
both quite good actually and we've shown
in our simulation that they do pretty
well
but there's one disadvantage is one is
you know they
um they can't really deal with the batch
effect so you can
have to do batch correction so that's
one thing sometimes phenograph you need
to do down something because it takes
too long although there's a first
implementation now but it's still a
little bit
you know hard to actually analyze very
big data sets with
it and then at the end of the day you
don't actually really know what the
labels of the populations that you're
getting so you have to do some
post-processing and
and you know again as as ella had sort
of talked about you can do meta
clustering and then you can
color code and there's lots of things
that you have to do after that whereas
for us
we get it for free we get the labels we
know where the populations are because
that's how we design the algorithm
so it's strike a very good balance
between doing the manual gating where
by design that's how you construct your
population and the totally
unbiased discovery where we're looking
at everything so we're sort of doing
that
but we're doing it in a way we can
define the population so we have a lot
more details into comparisons
performance
and we've shown it works pretty well
none of these methods detect the pd1
biomarker that i talked about
in in the presentation and we have other
examples where they fail to detect
important biomarkers
dr guitar we have time for one more
question
what kind of pre-processing is required
for fast
example of down sampling concentration
anything else yeah so no down sampling
because it's pretty fast
and it can be paralyzed pretty
efficiently don't you don't need to
concatenate because it's a per sample
processing and that's very very
important
again uh we just need to you know do the
typical pre-processing where you want to
remove your
dead cells and maybe um you know your
sort of singlets uh life cells and
potentially you know
lymphocytes so just getting down to the
population that you want to process so
again just like a ls sort of talked
about but once that's done you can just
plug it in and we can we have lots of
tools for doing these kinds of things as
well
dr garchardo thank you again for your
presentation today of your time
would you like to provide any closing
remarks before we
go today i would i mean i would you know
i would thank everybody because i think
it's great it's
phenomenal uh symposium i actually woke
up very early just to
to watch the first um one you know being
on on the
um west coast but what i would actually
i mean it would make a call especially
in the cubby time you know if you have
data if you
if you haven't shared it yet because
often times flow saturn which is not as
short as much as some of the other
single cell genomics and samusaitov
we're really looking forward to
realizing some of these data
integrating data so that we can
accelerate discovery i think we're in a
time when that's really needed so if you
can do that please do it and if you need
help we can help you do that
thank you again dr corchardo and i want
to thank all of our presenters dr mckee
dr ramirez dr cotardo thank you all for
your great presentations today for your
time
and thank you to our audience members
for joining us today
questions submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time
of your registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand through
september
of 2021. until next time everyone
take care stay healthy and bye bye
great thanks